[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017 fall
chess classic we're at halftime at the
2017 fall chess classic 5 of 9 rounds
have been played this is your weekend
wrap up two rounds were played on
Saturday and Sunday
Kovalev jariabek and Mayer in Group A
had outstanding showings with one and a
half points out of two each and the
field has shaped up we see the potential
contenders emerging in this event the
fields combined have a prize fund of 36
thousand dollars the top prize in Group
A is 6 grand the top prize in Group B is
4 grand we play one classical round of
chess every day through Thursday
September 14 rounds begin at 1:00 p.m.
here in st. Louis except for the last
day which begins earlier we close out
the weekend the end of round 5 daniel
narrowed its key is here with me today
with the black pieces he defeated teed
ground Petrosyan going into this round
the tournament so far how would you
describe it for you well it's been going
a bit sluggishly I lost at first round
against Irish who played a positional
masterpiece I wasn't able to equalize in
the opening so not exactly the best way
to start off a tournament after that I
made a couple of drawers I had some
chances in some of the games but that
you know I wasn't as crisp as I would
have liked to be so my previous
tournament Washington International was
a disaster so you know it wasn't going
as badly but I really felt the urgency
to at least win a game because you know
the tournament doesn't last forever so
this game I came really prepared to work
hard and to try to outplay him well
today it was your first victory across
the board against Petrosyan he has this
really interesting move queen g4
counter-attacking my knight and here I
wouldn't have taken with a pawn because
this is very dangerous but I saw this
line Knight takes d5 pawn takes e5 and
again
trap because of rook takes e5 then he
doesn't just bail out he takes on h6
very troublesome but I have this move f5
Queen takes f5 Queen e1 check and I pick
up this Bishop and I continue this line
six or calf eight but I think the black
emerges more or less alive here and
actually I think he wins in this
position so I was happy with with what I
calculated here and Petrosian seems to
arrive at the same conclusion and so he
played g4 to stop f5 f6 protecting the
pawn and here was his main mistake I
think after Knight takes e5 now he was
in whoops he was in very acute time
pressure at this point and so I was very
surprised by King g2 he should have
simply bailed out
I guess Bishop e3 and I basically I
would have reached move 30 and offer to
draw here it's just a maybe you know
black has tiny tiny push chances but if
white makes you know one or two careful
moves it's just a draw but he played
king g2 trying to maintain the tension
but what he missed I think was that this
pin is actually very important and I
made this move king f7 which i think is
the key the key move in the whole game
and all of a sudden it turns out that
Bishop f4 which is probably what he
intended meets with Knight takes f3 and
he can't take my rook because I have a
variety of different reputations the
nicest being Knight age 4 King has to go
forward and I think that I'm just
checkmating him and you know fairly
one-sided fashion but this was an
important line to calculate and so he's
forced to resort to trades and here he
can't take my rope he has to play up
three and now I make this move Queen c5
which he definitely I think missed
threatening checkmate on g1 he has to
defend and now I'm able to [ __ ] this
pawn structure which doesn't seem very
meaningful but I think it is because
this King is going to have chronic
problems and with 30 seconds to make 11
moves I think that he made several
further inaccuracies he a lot of my pawn
to go to b3 which i think was the first
and then we kind of moved around he he
was a little bit aimless here and he
allowed further concessions this square
on g3 the square enough for I could feel
the you know some sort of mating
combination already in the works and I
have this beautiful battery and I won't
go too deeply into the details here I'm
sure that he he had a more careful way
to play here I think he can still hold
the draw but in the critical moment on
move
38 actually I move 40
which is very symbolic this often
happens he had you know ten seconds and
he should have just stayed put with
Queen g2 and I didn't see a concrete way
to actually make progress I would have
continued bothering him with Queen d6
etc etc but I think that white can
basically hold the balance here but he
played the move Queen d3 trying to solve
his problems immediately he wants to go
to to d7 and deliver Perpetual but
there's a big flaw here I play Queen h2
which is totally devastating now he saw
this I'm threatening Queen f2 checkmate
and I'm attacking the pawn it looks like
white as perpetual we need 7 check and
if King g6 then simply queen up 5 check
and the subtlety here that he calculated
is king h6 Bishop takes g5 check very
impressive and time pressure to see this
if King takes d5 this would be quite
masochistic after Queen g7 checkmate so
I have to take with a pawn and here he
has okay Queen takes c6 is probably also
a draw but the simplest is just this
perpetual and the king is completely
imprisoned so it's a draw but what he
missed is that I can I can play King f8
and at first I thought okay Queen see a
check King e7 and I thought yes yes yes
I'm escaping perpetual then I saw Queen
b7 for King and I thought no no it's
still a draw but then luckily I was able
to see Bishop c7 which wins instantly
because I'm no longer threatening
checkmate but he's out of productive
checks and he's not going to be able to
save the h3 pawn which I'm going to take
with check and after I do that the queen
is going to return somewhere safe to d6
or e5 and then I'm just gonna promote
this pawn so for example I mean if he
plays like I don't know Bishop e3 won
pretty one-sided demonstration I pick up
another upon here and after something
like this you know I can just resign I'm
gonna push this to h1 and and far beyond
so he play d5 a last-ditch attempt to
complicate matters which I had actually
first seen because Queen takes h3 I
think it wins after Queen g2 and Queen
d5 I spent some time calculating this
but it's definitely very scary this King
becomes active and there's a much better
option in Queen h1 check which is just
instant checkmate he need to Queenie for
track and the combined forces of Queen
Bishop and this pawn on b3 which has
finally turned out to be rather
meaningful in the end is completely just
curtains for the King so if King F 1
then we enough three will transpose to
the game
and he played King d1 we have to recheck
if King c1 then this only staves off
checkmate for a couple moves and it's
never good when not only do you win a
bishop but you win the whole house the
queen and the king after Bishop III
check so King he won his force and after
Bishop f2 he threw in the towel because
King f1 is a very typical Czech netting
you know I wouldn't even call this a
combination I guess uh a little you know
sickly little cousin of a combination
but here I have a very nice choice
between the ravioli with queen f1 and
the you know the triple decker burger
with Queen h2 so he decided not to allow
that undersigned after Bishop f2 so I
think it was a decent effort the key
mistake being definitely I haven't
checked with the computer yet but I'm
sure of this as as I can be he shouldn't
have played King g2 practically speaking
that was almost the decisive mistake and
this would have just led to a drop so I
guess I got a little bit lucky but I'm
happy with the way I manage to do
finesse that advantage into something
actually tangible good for you in a
tough tournament 40 grand Daniel you're
one of the more colorful characters we
see around here at the Chess Club
I love getting b-roll of you in the
tournament hall because you really wear
your emotions right on your face a lot
different from other players
does that come naturally or is that for
some kind of conscious psychological
edge it comes to naturally I am I'm not
very proud of it I it's something that I
I consider to be you know full
disclosure psychologic I mean I wouldn't
call this psychological weakness I don't
think it helps my opponent necessarily
but it's something that I've tried to
lessen throughout my career because I'm
definitely very emotional at the board I
think I'm a lot calmer in real life but
in the heat of the moment especially
after a mistake I'm very tough on myself
so often I you know can't help myself
and the the inner the inner Daniel
that's costing it myself non-stop it
kind of shows himself so it's definitely
not for some sort of psychological
trickery reason it's just something
that's come naturally to me throughout
my career and hopefully I can I can
eventually reach some sort of a Zen
state where at least that that comes
into the
around well hey Kasparov is pretty
emotional too exactly all wrong right
yeah well Daniel thanks for staying late
and joining I do appreciate it
after five rounds just four more to go
let's take a look at the standings in
Group A after five narrowed its key is
tied for fifth place still a point out
from first no one has emerged as a
runaway train as of yet Monday's game of
the day
Gehrig Meyer against Vladislav Kovalev
both players are in the top three after
a weekend we come back to you
five rounds have been completed and in
Group B I'm here with Grandmaster
Antonio's Pavley Dee's who today with
the white pieces defeated his opponent
shetan knee Antonio's congratulations
the first tournament ever in the US you
said how are you enjoying your time so
far it's very nice over here
I've never been to us even for a row
holidays I enjoy it really much and the
people are very nice as well not only
from the Chess Club but generally
they're very kind and they're willing to
help you we have I think at some point I
lost the control of the position maybe
here
Quincy 3 I thought here actually case is
threatening which would be five so I
have to move my queen one possibility
was to go Neff three and the other was
to go on g3 I think that going on an f3
is much it's better because of some
lines I mean okay if stakes and
something like this would happen and
then Queen g3 h4 h5 I think what
position is better but I played queen g3
because I wanted to have the same
position with some extra tempos again
easily and then h4 and I said that this
must be even better from your maybe
first Bishop g5 and then h4 h5 her
position looks crappy but I think after
23 maybe she can go Bishop c4 it's very
tricky because Knights force it takes I
take
take maybe Bishop d3 and position is
slightly better for white but I think
black can hold this if you compared with
the game I think it's much better for
here to play such an endgame maybe even
it's it's nothing for white not even an
advantage because I have kind of weak
structure
so basically when I played Bishop d7 I
was very happy because I protect and I
attack which is very nice I mean I have
given a three pawn but h5 comes and I
will I want to sacrifice on g6 c7 is
also weak
she cannot really move the night because
Cepeda night c4 I go night c6 again she
gives away other squares and here she
went rook c8 and I played h5 which was
not my first choice
firstly I want to play this Bishop d5
maybe it's stronger I'm not sure because
he has some problem in the align and I
think all the movies for her to go
Knight b6 and maybe I should continue
like this sacrifice on e6 okay man we
take like this is the same rock e6
and something like this and I think
white is probably much better I mean I
have a clear domination the file I have
a very good night on c6h5 is coming when
will come to e4 I have a safe
maybe it's winning I mean maybe differ
all so comes in 97 is a threat maybe
this is what I should play but I wanted
to to attack but we played Age 5 and now
she has this Bishop d7 and I'm not sure
what's going on now because basically I
wanted to sacrifice on g6 but now it's
not so good as Queen will come to a fate
and nothing really happens so I came up
with another idea not before I'm
threatening rook some rookie 2 moves
to trap the queen spread 96 and Clara
played Bishop d5 also I mean threatening
some rookie at some point for example if
she takes I take rook e8 rookie to win
the Queen it's a very nice variation may
be here system play like this and give
check but I couldn't really see how this
is going to protect on on g6 because
maybe something like will be won but I
can go twin rock inside I'm not quite
sure I mean it's a bit unclear because
she also has some good square Queen to
cook Oona 5 because there are always
these perpetual checks it's very
annoying for me I have to watch out
maybe I have to play something like f3
here just to hold the position and
sooner or later it will be really good
from or maybe I can first take on d6 and
then come lucky 7 I don't know I think
it must be objectively better for white
but I have to be careful so plate this
Bishop a5 nice run now I played Bishop
e5 I think it's a good move because I'm
threatening located H everything up to
to the screen I mean see she took the
pollen a3 and I managed to not to win
the Queen but to trap her in the edge of
the board so she took only five I took
Knight B 5 and now I thought for sure
for sure minutes and I couldn't really
find a way to win a mini six was my
initial intention but she goes King g7
and if I take on f7 I thought it might
be somehow running but it's here's again
this ah even rocket eight I didn't see
located but I saw that she can go cone
eight six and it's a very bad but
anyways it's a checkmate now so this was
not possibly six and I'll try to come
and manipulate this really nice move
because now I'm threatening actually six
because there's no
a real threat I mean I can take with a
queen on May 3 in the same variation for
example if nothing is 6 I did with the
Queen and ok it must be winning for me
I'm telling you Queenie 528 it's too
much for her
but I think here she should play night
before and it felt to me that I have to
be some somehow better because again I'm
threatening also bishops e6 a deadly
threat because the knight is handling
and the rook is hunting and then night
comes on d5 in turn f6 and he's weakened
the position because doesn't give the g7
bishop now after 94 I'm I'm not quite
sure how how I would react it feels like
I have to be somehow better but really I
couldn't find the way maybe I should
take Bowie 6 I don't know if f6 is
possible now for Graham King d7 I take
take ok this should be winning somehow
don't know exactly but it looks really
annoying for black maybe some but see to
consider in this point and I have this
very nice move I think 92 and everything
collapses I mean I protect all my pieces
and in the next move I take with a
knight on c3 and it also protects I mean
the bishop on d5 likes in the game but
ok no it's totally winning I have an
extra piece and it's just a maid and
somehow it will finish at some point
well how do you evaluate your
performance in this tournament so far
well I think I've played some really
interesting openings I'm satisfied
because I had been playing Church for
for some period so it's a bit like a
combat for me I lost first round two
Ramirez played a quite decent game and
also his performance in the tournament
is really amazing superb yeah but I
think he lost today anyway I mean he's
playing really really good I got another
game with white against Arriba's and it
was a nice comeback from me after losing
first round the next two games I played
with black it was quite ok and I drew
them
I kept chances to win but ok draw with
black against Grandmaster it's a good
result I'm I'm I'm happy with my
performance here and I'm looking forward
to the next rounds well you said this is
your first tournament in the US and not
to mention the Chess Club I hate to put
you on the spot but have you given any
thought to maybe come in here to st.
Louis full-time yeah I've thought about
it and we're discussing with just Club
here and maybe I have to apply to the
University and actually my visit here is
also connected with watching the Chess
Club the Campos Central University I
hope we find some some way that I will
be here next day next year K this year
so the did you lie a to apply for for
the University but even if I don't
manage to come here it's a very nice
experience and maybe I will be here for
the protest in the future as well I wish
you the best certainly antonio's have
ladies let's take a look at the
standings after five rounds in Group B
this weekend saw the slight displacement
of Alejandra Ramirez no longer in clear
first that honor is now bestowed upon
Alan P chat on Monday picha takes on
Chandra with the white pieces to see if
he can extend his undisputed lead each
rounds notable players will be
interviewed in this recap but remember
to follow the games live every
day at 1:00 p.m. in st. Louis via Ches
24 and us chess champs dot-com